Good morning, John.
I'm a little bit freaked out by all the dying
birds, and now that thousands of birds have
fallen prey to this bizarre and seemingly
unprecedented event, I have found several
entirely insane theories about what happened
to them. Most of them have to do with secret
government weapons programs, whether it be
acoustical or, like, very specified biological
weapons delivery, and I really just have to
say, those are almost the most boring conspiracy
theories I have ever heard.
I’m not even going to tell you the details
of these conspiracy theories, because they’ve
got no chutzpah! They take no pleasure in
their own absurdity!
So John, I’ve put together a list of the
*voiceover* TOP 5 MOST RIDICULOUS CONSPIRACY
THEORIES OF ALL TIME. *weird bleh noise* Conspiracy
theories that should make these lame bird
conspiracy theories feel ashamed of themselves.
Number one: The Phantom Time Hypothesis, which
postulates that the years between 614 and
900-something AD never happened. A group of
people made those years up, along with everything
that ever happened during those years, and
all of the artifacts that date back to those
years. Charlemagne, for example, is of course
a fictional character. You thought this was
the year 2011? Turns out, it’s, uh, it’s
1714. Makes you feel young again.
Number two: Nazi UFOs. I love this one because
you take UFOs, already a conspiracy theory,
and you say that, that’s not enough. Because
it turns out that Nazis had UFOs as early
as 1930, and before the end of World War II,
they took all their UFOs, and they put them
on a secret base in Antarctica. And ever since
then, those UFOs have been rummaging around
the earth, bothering country folk in their
nightgowns. Brilliant! I wish I could think
of crazy crap like that!
Number three: Kentucky Fried Chicken Causes
Sterility, But Only in Black Men. This prize-winner
dates back to the 1950s, back when the KKK
was still powerful. Colonel Sanders, rumored
to have been a Klansman himself, created a
secret recipe of seven herbs and spices and
a fertility agent that only sterilized black
men, while leaving white men as virile as
the horn of an African rhino.
Number four: Microsoft’s Secret Wingdings
of Terror. So Microsoft has this font. It’s
called Wingdings. It’s basically an easy
way to get clipart out of a font. You type
and symbols come up. For example, if you type
a capital NYC, you get this *image on screen
of skull and crossbones, Star of David, and
thumbs up symbols* which implies of course
that killing Jews is A-OK. It was actually
a big enough deal that when Microsoft later
released Webdings, they actually did embed
a secret message into it. With Webdings, if
you type in NYC, you get eye, heart, and a
city skyline.
And number five: The Reptilianoids. The winner
of the most freakin’ stupid crazy conspiracy
of all time goes to the guy who came up with
the shape-shifting, blood-drinking humanoid
reptile aliens that have been ruling the human
race since the time of the pharaohs. Dave
Ick, or Icky—icky icky ptang zoop boing—former
professional soccer player and morning show
sportscaster, has many followers, including
the father of balloon boy Falcon Heene, who
believe that many of the most powerful people
in human history are, in fact, shape-shifting,
blood-drinking reptilians from the constellation
Draco. The British royal family, most of America’s
presidents, and of course, Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie, all reptilians. They feed on human
guilt, fear, and aggression, and in order
to maintain their humanoid shape, they must
drink lots and lots of human blood. Here’s
a direct quote from his website: Al Gore,
vice president to Clinton, Illuminati, Satanist,
serious blood-drinker, and reptilian shape-shifter.
Those are my top five most ridiculous conspiracy
theories of all time. If, by chance, you thought
that some of those theories did not seem far-fetched,
I would request that you go see a therapist.
John, I’ll see you on Wednesday.
End screen time! Thank you to my friend Jesslyn
Shields for helping me write and research
this. There’s a link to her blog in the
dooblydoo, and thank you to Toby of tobuscus
fan for the epic Toby voice in the intro.
Also one of my favorite books of the year,
Shipbreaker, just won the Printz award, which
I’m very excited about. Congratulations
to Paolo Bacigalupi, and there are other things
around me that you should go check out. Thank
you to nerdfighters for always being awesome.